Wow that was definitely my favorite
dancer we've ever done both these ladies
were perfect last week and so has the
competition come have been amped between
you two because I mean two perfect
scores of the season you know you would
think so but I feel like it's kind of
like going to the top is making us like
stronger and our friendship we're like
yeah like it feels really good but can
they do it again tonight Val is trying
to get ginger to face her fears about
the dance that scares her the most the
Argentine tango it's a huge deal it's
taking it away from what is a little bit
more natural something like last week
and going to pull out and becoming a
panther right tonight Paige and Mark
will do the paso doble but remember when
Paige dance with substitute dancer Alan
Burstyn when Mark Ballas was injured
well the rumor mill was calling them
dating dancers well you set the record
straight for you tonight was that the
record straight I'm single
Paige is graceful and athletic on the
dance floor but she is one tough cookie
in the UFC Octagon so I'm gonna come in
I'm gonna come in and try and get your
waist okay now I think I'm in pretty
good shape so I asked her to show me how
she completes a smackdown
round two yeah I give up but let's see
how I can take a punch